hallo leute ich sie teure mal waren
willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender video unboxing-video in
dieser folge geht es um den em pe
adventskalender das ist keine werbung
für imp mir hat das jemand in die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich ihn mal
ausprobieren soll
und ich mag das ist so ein merchandise
die shop ich denke aber jeder von euch
kennt ihn schon sonst hättet ihr nicht
aufs video geklickt oder sind wir mal
ehrlich oder jetzt auch video geklickt
weil ihr wisst dass mit mir alles spaß
macht ich freue mich wirklich sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr
wehrendorf diesen adventskalender weil
ich gar keine ahnung habe was da drin
sein könnte ja ihr könnt mir jetzt in
die kommentare schreiben
die kühe mein t shirt ist also diesen
adventskalender öffnet man so und da
sind 24 schwarzen säckchen ich bin so
ein kleiner aufbewahrungs messi und ich
freue mich gerade darüber weil die
sächsin kann man wirklich wieder
verwenden und einen eigenen
adventskalender basteln
die zahl kann man glaube ich sogar auch
ab machen also da gibt es schon mal
einen daumen nach oben hashtag nur
werbung so sieht er aus es ist eine
kleine schnitzeljagd weil man erst mal
die zahlen wirklich suchen muss glaube
es ist kreuz und quer macht auf jeden
fall schon mal spaß
ich habe gemerkt dass ich auf jeden fall
während des auspacken
den preis für den adventskalender wissen
muss weil ich sonst nicht weiß ob es
sich lohnt 70 euro hat dieser
adventskalender gekostet an muss auf
jeden fall guter stoff drin sein ich bin
mittlerweile schon so im weihnachts
villingen drin ich weiß wir haben noch
nicht mal halloween türchen nummer 1 ist
hätte ich irgendwie gar nicht so viel
mit jugendlichen immer eins ist eine
schwarze kerze ja ich find's cool dass
es bei nacht und ich hatte noch nie eine
schwarze kerze also dann die stücke
totenkopf das zweite türchen 7 dazu
gemacht das zweite türchen ist ein
empedocle ding also dem was sie auf
klamotten nehmen kannst oder bügeln
enttäuschend überlege gerade wenn alles
einfach emp möchte
dann weine ich ok computer nummer drei
enttäuscht mich nicht ich habe schon
eine ahnung
[Gelächter]
ich habe gerade so gemischte gefühle mal
ehrlich das ist ja wohl absolute schrott
oder also ist gut so eine schwarze also
jo 70 euro mehr wir wir erinnern uns 70
eur 64 wie man jetzt ein kleines
ratespiel
wenn er so buttons drin sind dann weine
ich möglich wisst ihr bei den shopping
queen adventskalender hab ich gedacht
was wir da schon drin sein
ja wie heißt diese dinger noch mal
ansteckbuttons sorry was soll das sind
was was sind das für das ist 1 70 eur 1
kalender was ist das das sieht so aus
wie wenn man was bei mp bestellt ist man
das so zusätzlich einfach da drin krieg
sowie sonstiger wir haben noch ein paar
buttons wenn es nicht besser wird
okay ich bin ein friedlicher mensch ich
gebe das festgelände chance vielleicht
dreht bis platziert und tüchern 5 wird
uns voll überraschen stoff drin
das sind 1 euro/t die artikel das sind
wirklich das sind artikel kosten links
die mütze hat nicht mal eine gute
qualität in christmas
ich hoffe dass ihr nicht vorhatten euch
diesen adventskalender zu holen und ich
euch jetzt von einer enttäuschung
bewahren kann dafür lebe ich okay
türchen nummer sechs es ist nikolaus was
bekommen wir an nikolaus ich freue mich
drauf weil super was erwartet uns
mein gott das ist deren ernst ich glaube
ich glaube das ist deren ernst
das sind magnete mit deren werbung drauf
im he also okay es kann ja auch sein
dass ich dumm war und irgendwie nie also
hahaha magnete und buttons und was zum
aufrufen
okay kommt leute ich hab ich habe mich
noch nie so richtig bei einer wende
aufträgt türchen nummer 8 was erwartet
uns da drin
oh mein gott die gleiche kerzen vom
zürcher noch mal eins ich raste aus
jetzt habe ich sogar zwei kann ich jetzt
ein adventkranz daraus basteln hammer
türchen nummer 9
du bist du natürlich nummer 7 vergessen
türchen nummer 7 sorry war geil im pvp
öffner hammer dankeschön zum glück steht
auch überall emp drauf damit auch wenn
die leute zu mir nach hause kommen mit
ihrem peer werbung zu weihnachten voll
gefüllt werden typische nummer 9 kommt
das dann kann eigentlich nichts mehr
toppen wir diskutieren über neun
meine fresse schweißband die neunziger
lassen grüßen die zweitausender oder
hummer vor herbies danken vier tische
nummer 10
die verkaufen so geile sachen auf ihrer
website und geben einen so ein schrott
oh mein gott
[Musik]
der faster im meetingraum und dachte
sich ja wisst ihr was wir verkaufen
einfach adventskalender mit button und
[Musik]
emp werbung artikel und das verkommene
70 euro die leute kaufen das sind denken
dass die kohle sagt aus unserer website
kriegen aber nein nein nein
überraschen sie mit meldet nummer 11 und
werdet jetzt mich glauben noch eine
christbaumkugel war ja schon aber sie
special weil sie ist schon kaputt seht
ihr diese kugel schon kaputt also nicht
nochmal das gleiche
nein nein nein nein nein ich finde es
super dass ich das team 12 ein
schlüsselband bin ich zwölf oder was
muss ich meinen schlüssel um meinen hals
trag mehr hat sich das ausgedacht wer
dachte dass das eine gute idee ist dass
etwas gutes drin sein
ich checke aber nicht mal so sein soll
wenn ich 70 euro ausgeben um jemanden
zum beispiel adventskalender oder mir
selber adventskalender zu kaufen und
wirklich jeden tag so ein artikel auf
machen glaube das muss man das wasser
legen
ich glaube das ist so ein ding was
meinem wasser auflösen dann hast und
handtuch ja glaubst ein handtuch toko
schreiben sie natürlich nicht drauf
darfst du raten noch mal 14 im
schlüsselanhänger passend für deine
schlüsselband dann kannste dir schön es
so aus wie neben p mitarbeiter wenn du
damit um gehäuft kann es sein dass es
irgendwie so für emp mitarbeiter gedacht
ist das ist doch zeug was du
kritik am 18 gott ich hoffe es aber so
eine dritte kerze klar da wird noch eine
perücke um den adventskranz voll zu
machen
da kann ich nur 16 wohnhaus großen
kirchen 16 das große nein ring cache pro
jahr was mich aufs nächste festival hier
klar
oh mein gott ein regencapes mit cmv
werbung kann es kann es noch besser
werden später richtig vom wunsch 17 rp
so schirmherr
warum kann ich nicht aufhören zu grinsen
nummer 17 sind einfach nochmal zwei
magneten seit halten sich an meinem
kühlschrank schade nummer 18 ihr
verrückten nudeln noch eine
christbaumkugel tander so jetzt hab ich
schon 3 ob ich leider nicht kaputt
[Musik]
nummer 19
guck mal waren winzig kleiner emp fehlt
freilich zwei davon den nummer 20 war
doch einer drin paar mangold hier drauf
so der hammer oder soja dass bügel ich
mir da so drauf sitzen 21
jetzt verwöhnen die uns aber wirklich
jetzt persönlich sie uns ein mp beute
geil 22 noch eine kerze einladung ja
jetzt ist ein adventskranz vollständig
ich weiß auch nicht was ich gemacht
hätte wenn nicht endlich gekriegt hat
richtig kugel ist welche nummer 23
ja die vierte christbaumkugel so wir
haben das 24 türchen und es könnte ja
noch sein dass das alles so dieser
schrott war und man jetzt seien 70 euro
artikel bekommen dass ihr so als
vorbereitung ihr werdet 23 tage lang
provoziert um dann das richtige zu
kriegen guter plan
[Musik]
frohe weihnachten leute fröhliche
weihnacht überall ihr also eben p
vielleicht liegt das ja irgendein
mitarbeiter das ist eine absolute
abzocke und eine frechheit und ich bin
sowas von enttäuscht von euch ich dachte
hier wird ein cooler merchandise shop
und mir fehlen einfach die worte
dass ihr eure kunden so abziehen wollte
diesen ganzen müll den ihr dafür
produzieren hat lassen ich meine kerze
ist ein cooles ding so als zwischendurch
ist es weihnachten natürlich sollte man
gekehrt sind und so eine christbaumkugel
kann da auch drin sein man kann ja nicht
jedes türchen mit irgendwas wertvollem
fühlt weil es kostet am ende januar 70
euro aber ihr habt einfach müll gemacht
ihr zählt eure kunden mit diesem kreis
kalender ab und es finde ich absolut
uncool und ich weiß nicht vielleicht
übersehe ich irgendwas vielleicht soll
das so sein vielleicht lieben die kunden
mp so sehr dass sie halt nur emp merge
haben möchten das kann ja auch sein dass
es leute gibt aber dann macht doch
wenigstens emp artikel die 70 euro am
ende wert sind und nicht diesen ich weiß
ich habe ich mich vielleicht übersehen
habe 70 euro
70 euro seine hauptfigur star wars zeug
ihr hättet so einen coolen
adventskalender machen können ich habe
auch echt erwartet dass
ich die teile irgendwie drin sein wird
tasten und figuren und was weiß ich von
sachen die auf irgend shop sind und ihr
habt einfach reingemacht wer möchte denn
eine farbige mütze tragen wo er im p
draufsteht ich kaufe auch nicht nütze
bei elsers damit die der fed und große
lust drauf schreiben ja ich weiß im psn
bisschen lifestyle und die leute blieben
emb und es ist ja auch cool aber nein
tja leute ich hoffe euch das video
gefallen vielleicht ist ja entertainment
mir dabei zuzuschauen wie ich mich zu
tode aufträge ich bin enttäuscht ich bin
so wie ich bin
man schaut euch einfach
schämt euch einfach ins knie ich hoffe
die leute die dafür verantwortlich sind
haben ganz schlecht das weihnachtsfest